Thank you all for
joining me with me today.
I'll be going through live
demo, as well as some examples
and background about why R is
very exciting, how you can get
started in an immediate plan
and then a long-term plan
about how to be successful using
our [INAUDIBLE] statistical
program.
So first off, a
little bit about me.
Who am I?
This is my face if you
haven't seen me before
or met me in person.
I originally got
started with statistics
and using statistical analysis
as a master's student.
I was doing exercise physiology,
looking at how exercise
is beneficial for brain health.
Now, when I first got
started using statistics,
I was using mainly point
and click Interfaces, things
like SPSS, Excel, origin.
So-- [AUDIO OUT] a couple
of different things--
my statistics in SPSS, my
data cleaning and organization
in Excel, and then finally,
my plotting and origin.
So it often meant that I had
to change things around or flip
them when I was switching
between programs.
Eventually, I ended
up in a PHD program,
where I was analyzing
a mouse behavioral data
with a neurobiology program.
And this is where I really
got my first taste of R.
We had an Intro To Statistics
course in my second year.
And we used R for some of
the basics in that course.
And once I got started with
R, I was like, oh, this
is really exciting.
I like the statistical
programming aspect,
where I was doing coding
and doing everything
in R, rather than
having to switch
between a lot of
different programs,
and got interested in
data science through that.
While I had that
course, I did find
that I needed to
learn a lot more,
beyond that was just you
given to me in this one month
or so-- this two
month long course.
So I actually got involved
with the R for DS,
or R for Data Science Online
Learning Community, which
is still around today.
And basically,
it's a slack group
where people are able to go
in, share questions, interact
with code, or just share ideas.
And out of this was born
the Tidy Tuesday project,
which is a weekly data project.
And I help post this,
where every week, I
uploaded data set.
Community members
attack it with R.
And then the Tidyverse, create
plots or statistical analysis
and then shared the
examples on Twitter.
And it's been a
really good project
for continuous learning,
in terms of every week,
there's a new data set.
So you can track things
out in a different way
than you're used to, rather than
doing the exact same thing over
and over, as well as it's
a distributed community.
So even if you don't
have local people who
are using R around you,
you can learn online
with an online community.
And lastly, I joined our
studio about a year ago.
I'm on the customer success
team, as Rob mentioned.
And what I do is help our
professional customers better
use our professional
products, as well as
open source products to use R
in their enterprise settings.
What I really want
to get out of this
is that my journey might
be similar to yours,
in terms of a lot of
people get started with R
didn't start as
computer scientist
or didn't start as programming
in other languages.
This was their first experience
with using statistics
and programming together.
And that's kind of
who I'm anticipating
will be a lot of
the crowd today.
Maybe we'll have some
experienced R users,
and they can also get
something from this.
But I primarily aim this
at people who are just
getting started with R. So
maybe you've heard of R,
or you've heard of R studio,
you've heard of the Tidyverse
But when you first started
trying to get started with R,
youth faced some hurdles.
And so you wanted
to find some more
examples about how to get
started and be more powerful.
And this really
resonated with me.
And the basis for what
this presentation started
as was a blog post I wrote a
year ago, based off this tweet
by Jesse, who helped found R for
DS Online Learning Community.
And basically, she proposed
that if you'd started R
and didn't end up
continuing with it, what
were your stumbling blocks?
And some of the common
things that resonated with me
was things like this.
I didn't have examples
of code or people
doing the basic things
they needed to do,
basic multivariate tasks.
And I wasn't experienced enough.
For David here, interested in
R, but for a lot of people,
it was to high level.
So maybe they weren't ready
for full-blown enterprise level
data science.
They were just
trying to get started
with basic statistical
programming
and using the Tidyverse
to create some plots
or do some statistical analysis.
And lastly, my contribution was
I know it can be frustrating.
You're just like,
hey, I just want
to run my ANOVA in R. Getting
the data in, cleaning it
up, getting everything set
up can often be a hurdle
for a lot of people.
And I know back in the day,
it was a hurdle for myself.
I'm borrowing this
graph curve here
from JD Long, who is a data
scientist out in the world--
great guy.
If you have a chance,
you should look
at some of his
presentations that he gave
that our CEO [INAUDIBLE]
2018 or 2019.
And basically, the
premise of this graph
is that there's
this learning curve.
And as with anything,
when you initially
get started learning
something new,
you're here at what they call
the suck threshold, in terms
of things are hard, and
you're not very powerful.
With a bad learning
curve, you'll
actually see that
you stay here in this
not being able to do
much powerful things
for a long time.
So the goal for today is to
get us on this good learning
curve, where you're able to
get into this point of I'm
kicking ass.
I'm doing powerful things.
I'm creating something useful
in R. And I feel powerful.
And hopefully, this will get you
started on this good journey,
versus the bad journey
[INAUDIBLE] talked
about previously.
So first of all, why learn R?
I think the biggest
thing for me is
people will connect with
an amazing community.
Often, when you're doing
stats or programming,
you might be all by
yourself, in terms
of you could be siloed
in an academic setting,
or maybe other people in your
workplace are using just SQL,
or Excel, or some
other language.
So you're able to connect
with this larger community,
ask them questions, and gain
access to their expertise,
whether it's through things
like LinkedIn, or Twitter,
or other different resources,
like Stack Overflow or Studio
Community.
Additionally, programming
itself is basically a superpower
that everyone has access to.
Programming can level up
your skill set over something
like a graphic user
interface and allow you
to do things more efficiently.
And the thing for me
that I really liked
was that I could do
cleaning, analyzing,
plotting, and finally,
communication around my data
all in one place.
So I didn't have to
switch between a bunch
of different software
suites and paper
a bunch of different
software suites.
I was able to do
everything in R.
Reproducibility is a big thing
with statistical programming,
in terms of your data
product is based off of code.
You have an example of
exactly what you did,
rather than having to
ask somebody, well, hey,
what did you do to
clean up this data?
And they're like,
oh, I don't know.
It was a year ago.
With code, you're able
to actually reference
exactly what you did
and see what's going on.
You can do things
like automation,
where if you have
a repeated report,
you can just rerun your
code with new data.
And it will update
that report for you.
And obviously, it's free.
R is and open source language.
It's extremely powerful.
And all the packages that
add additional features to R
are also free.
So it's a great investment
at the very beginning.
We actually ran a survey
right before our last studio
conference and asked people
what they like best about R.
And again, the community
packages, the Tidyverse,
ggplot.
These were some things that
were very popular amongst users.
So being able to
be powerful quickly
and engaging with the
community is something that
really resonates across groups.
Lastly, hitting again
on why you should
be excited about
the community is
as Kim says here,
because it's fun,
and you learn so much without
having to seek it out.
So you're just able to passively
take information and learn
a lot by what other
people are doing.
[INAUDIBLE] over here has some
other examples, in terms of oh,
I can actually help
someone out, who's
six months behind me in
their learning process,
or commiserate over something
difficult, thank somebody,
see examples of data vis or
other excellent resources.
So hopefully, this reinforces
that the community is great.
And you're able to access
them and interact with them.
Getting into exactly what
we're covering today,
we'll be looking at the
basics of our studio,
reading data into R,
basics of data wrangling,
some exploratory data analysis,
basic statistics in R,
and finally, creating
a publication plot.
This resonates pretty well
with the total R for DS model
that Hadley Wickham and
Garrett Grolemund laid out
in R for data science.
Their textbook, in terms of
often statistical workflows
can look like this, where
you bring your data into R,
you tidy or clean it up somehow.
And then, you go through the
cycle of visualizing, modeling,
or statistical testing,
and transformation of data,
eventually creating
a data product
that you communicate, whether
it's R Markdown or Shiny,
or just a simple plot.
And all of this is wrapped
around by programming,
in terms of rather than having
to point click and do all
these other things, you're
able to write a flow
and syntax in R. And it will
create these things for you
and able to work through
the workflow here.
I really want to emphasize
that the other things
that we're not doing today,
which is covering what
statistical tests to run when.
We will not be doing a deep-dive
into statistical programming
or data science, in terms of
scaling out to the enterprise.
And I don't expect you to
100% it the first time.
This is just the
start of your journey.
And I'm hoping to again, get
you on that good learning curve
and get you started
down a path where you're
able to be successful quickly.
And again, that's the ultimate
goal is just eventually,
you will you'll reach a
point where you're like, hey,
this is really useful.
I'm actually being
powerful with this.
And you'll feel rewarded
in what you're doing.
As far as R and getting into
the meat of the presentation,
I wanted to emphasize
the difference
between R and RStudio.
So if you think of R, it could
be the engine of your vehicle.
So it actually will do all
the computation for you.
It is actually the code that
you're writing and executing,
whereas RStudio, the IDE
or Integrated Development
Environment is just an
interface to that engine,
allows you to have a nice
place to work and write
code, some user enhancements
that I'll walk through.
But R itself is
executing everything.
This basic example of the
RStudio Cloud interface
shows you the two examples.
So the console would be the
interface directly to R.
So you can write some code here.
You execute it.
And this actually created
a plot as its output.
You can also have outputs that
are more numeric or text based.
Those can output in the console.
But this right here itself
would be the RStudio interface.
I'll walk through this, watch
you do a live coding demo.
I just wanted you to get
a very brief overview
of what this looks like.
The other thing I
wanted to cover,
before we jumped
into live coding
was it between R and R Packages.
So you can think of
R as a new phone.
It's powerful.
It has some core features,
like calling, texting,
email, a web browser.
But you need to add additional
applications to do more things.
And R is exactly the same
way, where you can install
packages that add new features.
So things like the Tinyverse,
whether it's dplyr or ggplot
allow you to get new features
that you can then use in R.
And with that, I'd like to
swap over into the live demo.
So again-- let's see if I
can do this full screen--
this will be the
RStudio Cloud Interface.
I'll zoom in a little bit there.
So this is actually a
hosted version of RStudio.
So we have an option of
installing it on your desktop.
You can do that after the
fact and see using it locally
on your own machine.
But I wanted to start
with RStudio Cloud,
because I'm actually going to
share this workspace with you.
And you'll be able to interact
with the exact same code
and data that I'm using.
And you'll be able to
try it out without having
to install anything.
So here again is the
RStudio interface.
So if we were to work
directly in the console,
we could do some math.
So we're typing some code.
And we just do
three, plus three.
And you get your output of six.
It's often more useful,
rather than having
to write lung functions
in the console,
to rather write with them
inside a script or inside an R
Markdown Document.
So here, you're able to
write out longer things.
I have 50 lines of code here.
And I can write some
comments and do the things.
But I'm still able to
execute the code that I have.
So again, the three, plus three.
I get my output of six.
The other thing I want
to cover real quickly
is base R functions and objects.
So you can do math
or do anything else
and assign it to an object.
So in this case, we'll
assign three, plus five to x.
And then we could
actually call x.
And we can see that it
will then execute the math.
Additionally, we can see that
x has been stored as a value
here in our environment.
So when you're working
with data sets--
and all important data
set here in a little bit--
you can actually find them here
in the studio environment pane.
So that can be
useful if you're not
used to finding where
your data sets are.
Always look up here on the top
right for your environment.
You can also do
some other things,
like combine data
set or numbers.
So here, one through
five is now stored as y.
And there's some functions that
are just built into R-- things
like sequence,
which actually will
generate a sequence of
numbers, so zero to 10.
And it will iterate by
2, so 0, 2, 4, 6, 8, 10.
These are things that
are all built into R.
Additionally, you can
write your own functions,
which is where a lot
of power comes from,
in terms of going to create a
function here called add pi.
And this function basically
says, take something
that I input, and
add 3.14 to it.
So if I save this
and add pi to it,
we can see that three,
plus 3.14 gets us the 6.14.
Now, when we're talking
about these functions,
you may not use functions
for quite a while.
But a lot of
libraries are actually
built off of these functions.
So they give you
more interfaces,
where rather than having
to type this out itself,
you just call add pi.
And similarly, if
we use a library,
which is a collection of
functions, we can load it.
And this now gives us a bunch
of plotting functions, based off
of the ggplot library.
This will take a data
set-- in this example,
a car is data set--
and allow you to set up a graph.
So if it actually just
run the code here,
it will input a graph.
And you can see that I
have a graph of horsepower,
versus miles per gallon, and
then a linear model fit to it,
and a title.
The real big thing
that I love about R,
and a lot of the
Tidyverse functions
is that this is very
word based or verb based.
So I can look at this
and say, OK, well,
I want my x-axis
to be horsepower.
That's horsepower.
I want my y-axis to
be miles per gallon.
And you can see its
miles per gallon.
And then, I want to add
points to that plot.
So if I just call
this part right here,
we can see that graph of
horsepower vs. Miles per gallon
and have the nice plots here.
We can then add
more features to it,
so adding things like the GM
Smooth or that linear model
fit, and then changing the
title so that they look nicer,
rather than saying HP
and MPG, adding them back
so they say horsepower
and miles per gallon.
I'm covering this
pretty quickly.
And part of this will be able
to reference it in the future,
but just going through
that as a quick example.
Also, going to load
that Tidyverse library,
which has a lot
of other functions
and other libraries within it.
Mainly the ones we're looking
at are dplyr and Tidy R,
which are used for data
cleaning transformation,
and ggplot, which
already loaded,
which allows you
to create plots.
The last thing I want to
cover, related to Tidyverse
is the pipe function, which
you can think of as and then.
So if you're reading some code--
so here, I want to
take the code here.
And I'm going to take the
data from cars data set.
And then, I'm going to mutate
cylinder into a factor.
And then, I'm going to select
the columns, miles per gallon,
cylinder, displacement,
and horsepower.
So if we look at the--
scroll this down-- if we look
at that data frame cars data set
before we do anything
else, you can
see that has a lot of
columns, so miles per gallon,
all the way up to carb.
And we can see that
cylinder is labeled here
as a double, which
actually means
that it's as a numeric value.
When we do this
transformation here,
we take that data set, and then
change cylinder to be a factor,
and then select only
these four columns.
You can see that it will
actually change the data set.
So now, cylinder is
labeled as a factor.
And you only have the
four columns of interest.
The Tidyverse is based
around these functions, where
you have nice verbs to work with
that allow you to understand
what you're doing, even if
you're just getting started.
So yes, this may seem a
little intimidating right now.
But you are able to work
through these functions
and get a sense of what
you're trying to accomplish.
And then, again, we can
take that same data set
and create a plot with it.
So this point, instead
of doing a GM point,
I used GM box plot, which allows
you to create a quick box plot,
and then overlay another
jitter or jitter dot
points all over the graph here.
So we went over the quick
basics here, the console.
And I also wanted to show
you again, the environment.
So those data sets I was
working with-- in this example,
small DF--
you can see that it's here
listed inside your environment
pane.
So you can see the small DF.
And you can see that
it only has the four
columns, versus
our full data set
that we were
working with earlier
has a lot of different
columns-- the 11.
You are able to look at this
kind of like in an Excel
format.
So if you were to
do view, small DF,
you'll actually open
it in a new tab, where
you can scroll through it, and
look at it in a long format
that you'd want to.
You can also go into here,
and just click this pane here.
And it will do the
exact same thing.
So open up the data
sets, so you're
able to take a look at it.
So we covered the R
basics pretty quickly.
Again, the origin
of this whole talk
was based off a blog post I
wrote back on my blog here.
And what's interesting is
this covers a fake data set
about Alzheimer's
disease, and then
giving these patients a drug
and seeing how it changed
their cognitive function.
I wrote this whole
blog post in R.
So you see all these
graphs and text.
This whole thing
was written in R.
So as an example of the
power what you could do,
I can actually just
re-run this whole report
and create that blog post again.
And you can see in about 20
seconds, or five seconds, two
seconds, I've recreated
that entire thing.
So all the text,
adding the pictures,
rerunning all the
code, making the plots,
all that's been
recreate it quickly.
So this is one of the powers
of code, in terms of you're
able to reproduce what
you've been working on.
As a basic example, we can
think of Alzheimer's disease
as a decline in
cognitive function,
due to changes in brain.
So your brain
actually deteriorates
as you age with this disease.
And for an example, we're
looking at a novel drug.
And we're giving it a
couple of different doses
to males and females and
seeing how it changes
their cognitive function.
So the context isn't
super important.
It's just a data set
that we'll be using,
but at least giving
you a sense of what
we're getting started with.
Is that better?
Perfect, thank you.
Perfect, OK, I didn't want to
let you know that as we get
started with this second file
that this is actually in R
Markdown Document.
And if we compared that
to our R file here,
you can see that the text,
if we were to write it out,
gives you know this
error, because it's
trying to evaluate this code.
With R Markdown, there's
an intent of saying,
I'm going to write text
here that is describing
what I'm doing, or talking
through what the results are.
And then each of
these code chunks
here will actually allow
you to evaluate code
as you would expect.
So for the first example,
what we want to do
is load our libraries.
So again, these will
add new functions to R.
So we have the Tidyverse
for plotting, cleaning,
and other functions like
that, the broom package, which
cleans up statistical
outputs and make
them a little bit cleaner,
mid-R, which is some tables
and R Markdown outputs,
the read Excel package
to read any Excel files.
And then the here
package, which allows
you to do programmatic type
aiming a data sets to read them
in or file structures.
So we'll load these.
And they've been loaded now.
So the next step would
be to read in the data.
So with other interfaces,
you might go into File,
and Open A Data Set.
You are still able to
do that in our studio.
So you can tell our studio
either programmatically,
so write out code
saying I want to save
a data set known as Rod DF.
And I want to read it
in as an Excel file.
So if I do this, it will add
the Rod DF data frame in,
so it's read in
a new Excel file.
Or if maybe you wanted to
do it not programmatically,
you can also imported data set.
So go to File, Import Data
Set, and then go to Excel.
You can then browse and then
choose a data set of interests.
So here, we're looking at
the 80 treatment, open it,
and it will give you
a preview of what
the data set looks like, the
code to actually read it in.
And then, you can import
it that way as well.
Because I know exactly
what the data said is,
I just did it programmatically.
So again, I used the
Read XLS function.
And I read in the
data set as XLXS.
It's stored up here.
And if I want to, I can
take a quick look at that,
using the glimpse
function, which
just shows you an overview.
So it says how many observations
there are, number of variables,
and it gives you a quick peek at
what the actual variables are.
So this is actually
the top five or 10
examples across the data set.
Now that we've got
it loaded into R,
we can actually start using it.
So again, using
something like ggplot,
we can say, OK, we want to
use the data, Rod DF, which
is the same data
set we just loaded.
And we want to assign
mini mental status
exam or cognitive function
to be on the x-axis.
I'm then going to add the
GM density function, which
would tell it to create
a density plot, which
is similar to a histogram.
And we can see the distribution
of cognitive function
across our patient examples.
So this is quick
exploratory analysis.
You can see it's very
small amount of code.
You're really just saying what
data set, what are your axes,
and then what kind of
plot do you want to make?
And it will quickly
make this plot for you.
And this shows us that we
have a bimodal distribution.
We have a group of patients that
have a low Mini-Mental Status
Exam, so lower cognitive
function, compared
to this patient
population, which
has a higher cognitive
function closer to about 25.
Now that we've got
an exploratory graph,
maybe you want to take a look
at some basic stats about it.
So we can actually run a
new function, so again,
taking the Rod DF and
then summarizing it.
The summarize
function from dplyr
will actually say, OK,
take this data set.
And then, knock it down
to just these two values.
So I want to look at
the min and the max.
You can see the min here is
8.4, so that's the lowest
Mini-Mental Status Exam value.
And the highest is about 28.
But this just shows you
the raw range across it.
That's not all that useful.
So we can actually do
a second function here.
We can use group by.
So rather than just doing it
across the whole data set,
we can actually group
it by health status,
where the health status actually
will show Alzheimer's patients,
versus healthy patients.
So we run this, the Rod DF
grouped by health status.
And then, for our
summarize, we want
to get the min value, the
median value, and the max value,
where these correspond
to other code
to get started with here
that are part of base R.
So we can see that the
Alzheimer's patients generally
have a lower range.
So they have a min of 8.4.
The median is about 15.
And the max is about 25.
Compared to healthy patients,
we can see all of these
are above 20 for their
Mini-Mental status exam.
So that's pretty interesting.
But maybe, we want
to see something
more about the data set.
So we'll look at Account,
so a table function
of how many of each we have.
So again, taking the
Rod DF data frame
and then grouping by both drug
treatment and health status,
where we have a couple of
different doses of the drug.
We use a high dose, a low
dose, and then a placebo.
And we give this to
all of our patients
that either have Alzheimer's
or are healthy patients.
And we can see that we have
100 of each of these groups.
So each of the groups
have an equal amount
of subjects in them.
So it's a well
set up study here.
When we're thinking more
about some of our statistics,
it might be helpful to get
into some additional graphs.
So rather than just
doing a raw distribution,
we might look at it by a
few different groupings.
So again, something more similar
to where the drug treatment,
versus the health
status example.
So in this case, we have ggplot.
And we're loading our data
set of interest, Rod DF.
We're taking, on the x-axis,
drug treatment, so either
high-dose, low-dose, or placebo.
And then, on the y-axis, it
would be a dependent variable.
We'll look at
Mini-Mental Status Exam.
And then, we'll assign
color to be drug treatment.
This will basically
say that there will
be three different colors here.
So each of the drug
treatments will
get to be a different color,
rather than all the same.
We're going to build a
box plot, so it shows--
sorry about that-- box plot
showing the different examples
of the min, median,
and the range.
And they're going to facet
this or create small multiples,
according to health status.
So if we go here, we
can see for Alzheimer's,
versus healthy patients,
we can see a nice graph
of the Mini-Mental Status Exam.
So the high-dose, the
low-dose, and the placebo.
And then, here in
the healthy patients,
again, the distribution
around that, so the median
and the upper quartiles
for the high-dose, low-dose
and placebo.
Something I do want
to point out is
that these axes
aren't super pretty,
in terms of the drug
treatment has a symbol in it.
Mini-Mental Status
Exam is all lower case.
And we'd probably want to flip
this, so placebo, low-dose,
and high-dose are
arranged differently.
Rather than it going
from high to low,
go from placebo to high.
But we do have a
sense of there appears
to be a difference, in that the
healthy patients, regardless
of treatment, appear to be
having higher MMSE scores,
compared to the
Alzheimer's patients,
where the placebo
has a low MMSE.
And the low-dose
and the high-dose
increase it slightly with
that treatment there.
Again, just taking a quick
look at the raw data frame,
we can see re-running
this function,
we have age, sex, health status,
drug treatment, and an MMSE
as our dependent variable.
It's important to note
that these variables here
are actually labeled as
just text or character.
And we actually
want to save those
as a factor, which assigns them
a tier or a categorical label,
as opposed to just raw text.
These are numeric or
doubles, so we can leave them
as is, except for sex
is coded as zero or one,
where zero is male,
and one is female.
So we do want to do some data
cleaning here to get everything
off the ground correctly.
So we'll actually create a
new data frame or a new object
here, so sum data frame.
We're to take the
original raw data frame,
and then mutate it, where we're
changing sex to be a factor.
And the levels are
going to be 0 and 1.
And then, we're going
to assign labels
to that of male and female.
So basically, it
will go through.
R will read and say,
OK, there's zero here.
This will now be male.
There's a one here, so this
will be assigned female.
And it will change that and
then assign as a factor.
We're also going to change
drug treatment into a factor.
So we're going to mutate drug
treatment to be a factor,
again as drug treatment,
where the levels are
going to be placebo,
low-dose, and then high-dose.
So we're actually putting
them in the correct order
we want to see.
Lastly, we're also going to
mutate health status to be
a factor around health status
where the levels are going
to be healthy and
then Alzheimer's.
So if we run this
code, we can see
that the same kind of glimpse
here that we look at the data.
So the variables
all look the same,
but it says male here
as opposed to zero,
and here's that 1, and so
there should be a female
and we see a female,
and that these are also
labeled as a factor.
So health status and
drug treatment and sex
are all labeled as factors now.
So that's good, because
it gets us set up
for our future analysis, whether
it's statistics or plotting.
So again, we're going to
create a summary table here.
So again, this is
all the data set.
So when we're doing
our summary data frame
we want to take a look at means
or medians or standard error
and then the amount of samples.
So that's what we're doing here
is taking the original data
frame, reassigning
as the same name.
We're going to group this.
So basically take
all of these, group
it by sex, health status,
and drug treatment,
and then summarize around
our functions of interest.
So we'll get the mean.
We'll get the standard
error as calculated
by standard deviation
by the square root of n.
And then show the
number of samples
by using the n function
which is for number.
Lastly, we'll also
tell it to a ungroup
so that it takes away
that grouping variable
after it's already calculated.
So if we run this code, then
we can look at sum df again.
We can see that rather than
having 600 observations,
we've now gone to
12 observations.
So basically, the
different groups--
so male healthy placebo,
male healthy low dose,
female healthy placebo,
female healthy low dose--
all these have the mean,
the standard error,
the number of samples
calculated out.
So this is helpful in terms
of we've got our nice summary
statistics saved here
and we're ready to work
with those whether it was
plotting or just saving
those as a table itself.
If we wanted to, we could
save it at this point.
So using our fake drug,
ADX37, the summary
stats we could
save that as a CSV.
We're just going to keep
working since we know
that we're not stopping here.
If we did want to create
a summary plot of that,
we can again take
that data frame--
so the sum df rather than the
raw df that we've been working
with previously--
and again assign
an x and a y axis.
So here, we're taking the
x-axis, drug treatment,
the y-axis as mini
mental status exam mean,
we're going to assign a
group, which basically groups
those numbers together,
drug treatment,
and then a color
of drug treatment.
So we can see that we get
three colors as opposed to one.
We're going to increase
the size of the gm point.
So we're going to add
points to our plot
and make them a
little bit bigger.
So if this were say 1,
they'd be nice and tiny.
But we want it to be
a little bit bigger,
so we'll do it as 3.
And lastly, we're actually
going to rather than make
one plot where they're
all kind of overlaid here,
we're going to
facet it or create
small multiples, so facet grid.
And we're going to make it
where it's sex by health status.
So if we rerun that code,
we can see that now it's
separated out into four
plots rather than one,
where male and female
are here, and we
have the healthy and
Alzheimer's patients.
And then we finally see the
placebo, low dose, high dose
for the drug treatment.
And we can see the kind
of different comparisons
for the male and female versus
healthy and Alzheimer's.
So we're getting closer to
a publication plot here,
but it's still a little rough.
We're finally
getting to the ANOVA
in terms of walking
through that kind of slowly
and getting set up with the
actual statistical analysis
now.
So for this example, we're
going to create a new data
frame called stats data frame
since we already saved this
as a summary level.
So actually create
a new data set.
We'll start again with raw df.
We'll do our mutate again.
So we'll change
drug treatment to be
a factor, sex to be
a factor, and health
status to be a factor so that
it's ready to go for the ANOVA.
So we'll rerun this.
And again, we can
see with glimpse
that stats df, our
new data set, is saved
as a factor across the board.
And this is now labeled as
male and female as opposed
to 0 and 1.
The actual code for running
ANOVA, at least a type 1
sum of squares, is pretty simple
in terms of the basic setup
is use the AOV or
ANOVA function.
You assign the dependent
variable first,
use a tilde and then the
independent variable,
and you tell it what is
the data set of interest.
So here, we're using a
fake data set, data df.
If you want to do main
effects or interactions
there is a slight
variation there.
So for just main
effects you will
add your dependent variable,
your independent label 1.
So here sex, drug
treatment, health status
are all added individually
as main effects.
Or you can do main
effects interactions
by using a star
instead of a plus sign.
There is a couple of different
ways of doing ANOVAs.
I'm just showing
one example here,
and there's a whole lot of other
different statistical tests
that you can do in R. So again,
this is just a basic example
and there's some
textbooks I'll be sharing
about great examples of
going through choosing
a different statistical
test or approaching it
from a statistical
validity standpoint.
Just trying to get us started
with the basic setup here.
I did want to point out that you
can use the plus or the star,
but we don't want
to use commas here.
This would actually throw
an error, and that's OK.
It doesn't break anything.
It just says, you know,
it's not able to do this
because it's trying to assign
this in an improper way.
So always make sure and use a
plus to add only main effects,
or the star for the main
effects and interactions.
So we'll run it as the main
And now we can see that it's
saved our Alzheimer's Disease
ANOVA as a list object here.
And there's a bunch
of things going on.
And I will show what all
those different things
are here in one second.
So if we actually call
summary on that object, ADAOV,
you kind of get
a nice table here
of what you would expect to see.
Your degrees of freedom, sum
of squares, mean square, your F
value, and then your p value.
And it also tells you
the significance levels,
whether it's 0.1 or
all the way down to 0.
So you can see that there are
significant main effects as
well as an interaction of drug
treatment by health status.
So we'll follow up with
those, but this kind of output
here is not always
the most useful
in terms of working
with it in other ways.
So we can actually tidy this
up with the broom package.
And if we were to
look at tidy ad ANOVA,
we can see that it's in
a different format now.
It's a little bit cleaner.
So rather than having
this kind of ASIC output,
we've got it in a nice
data frame where you're
able to see all the
different things kind
of across a little bit cleaner.
And again, you could save
this to Excel or as a CSV
if you wanted to export
it, or you can just kind of
keep it here.
Because we did see main
effects and interactions,
we should follow up
with post hoc tests.
So we'll take a look at a couple
of different post hoc test
examples.
The first one would just
be a pairwise t-test
with the Bonferroni correction.
And the basic setup
here, if we take a look,
is that we're going to
save it as an AD Pairwise
so we know which one this was.
The pairwise t-test
function gets us started.
And we're going to assign
a stats df with MMSE
as our data set
of interest where
MMSE is the dependent variable.
And then we've got a little
bit weirder syntax here
that's hard to read but
I'll walk through with it.
So again, we're using
the stats df data frame,
and we're using the sex
column as the factor.
We're doing an interaction,
shown here with the colon.
And then using the
next factor, which
is drug treatment, another
colon for the interaction,
and then the stats df and
the health status column.
And lastly, telling it to
do a p-value adjustment
for multiple comparisons
of Bonferroni.
So we run that, and
we can again see
that it's saved as an object.
Again, I like to clean
this up a little bit
so I'll run tidy on it.
So we use the broom
package to tidy it.
And I'm actually going
to then mutate the p
value to round it so it's less
expansive rather than sig figs.
We kind of get this nice
just five significant units.
So we can see the
comparison here
where we're saying comparison
one, male placebo Alzheimer's
compared to male placebo
healthy is significantly
different as opposed to the
low dose in the healthy male
versus the placebo in
the healthy male not
statistically
significantly different.
That's just the quick
example of the Bonferroni.
If maybe you like the Tukey test
better you could also do that.
So here, we're using
the Tukey HSD function.
We're using the AD ANOVA data
set we've already created.
So that was our actual
ANOVA output from above.
And this syntax is
a little bit cleaner
where we say, run a
Tukey on this ANOVA
where the interaction of sex,
drug treatment, and health
status is of interest.
We're then going to tidy it
to clean it up like this,
take just the first
six values with head,
and create a nice table.
So if I do this,
we can again see
that we have our term,
the comparison here.
So female placebo healthy
versus male placebo healthy.
It's got your confidence
intervals low and high,
and then the adjusted p value
here for the Tukey test.
These are going to be pretty
similar to the Bonferroni
because the comparisons are--
or sorry, the groups are
very, very different,
but you'll obviously
need to choose
whichever statistical test
makes sense for your analysis.
Lastly, in the next
couple of minutes
I'm going to go through a quick
guide to the publication graph.
So I'm actually going to create
a data set and actually can
create this with the
tribble function, where
I can assign a column and then
all the different values in it.
So if I run this
function here, you
can see that column
A gets A, B and C--
A, B and C. And column
B gets 1, 2, 3--
1, 2, 3 in it.
We assign the column names
by adding a tilde before it
and then each of the columns
below it get added correctly.
Rather than just
adding random data,
I'm going to assign these
as the proper groups.
So I actually
looked back through
the pairwise comparisons above
and found the groups that
were significantly different.
So the low dose Alzheimer's
male and the high dose
Alzheimer's male
versus the placebo.
And then the low dose
Alzheimer's female
and the high dose Alzheimer's
female versus placebo
was significantly different.
So we're creating a new
data set based around that.
And then reassigning our
factor levels there so
we see drug treatment, sex as
a factor, and health status
as a factor as well.
We're finally getting to
that publication plot,
and it looks a lot wordier
or longer than our plots
from above.
That's because we're doing
some more customization.
So if we look at the
actual plot here--
and I'll pull it up in the
window so you can see it nice
and big--
there you go.
You can see a few
different things.
So we're doing our basic
setup where we have our data
as the sum data frame.
We're assigning X as
the drug treatment and Y
as the mini mental
status exam mean.
We're going to fill it or
assign a color according
to drug treatment and
group it by drug treatment.
And then we're going
to add error bars.
So this white, gray, black
is according to the fill,
and then we've assigned the
error bars which are really
small here according to group.
I built out that
data set above here
because I'm actually assigning
small asterisks to the graph.
And that can be found with the
gm text I've assigned here.
So this is data according
to the sig fig data frame
that we set up and adding
a label of an asterisk.
I also changed a couple
of the theme items,
so changing it to be a white
background versus a gray,
changing the access text size.
All these different things are
kind of at your discretion.
So maybe you're like oh I want
to add these different changes
or make it a little
bit prettier,
this would be an example.
I'm going to leave this here
for you to play around with.
So I will be sharing
that at cloud setup
so you can actually
take a look at this
and pull out different
things and try it out.
But the basic idea is
that we create based off
of the data set.
We assign the x and y axes.
What type of graph do we want
to make-- an error bar, a bar
graph.
And then we want to make small
multiples or multiple graphs
according to sex
and health status
where we see sex and
health status again.
Lastly, we'll add our labels.
So rather than kind of
blah or small descriptors
we have a nice big drug
treatment and cognitive
function, and then a
figure caption here.
So Figure 1, the effect of novel
drug treatment with our groups
and the total, as well as
a significant indicator.
Lastly, we can take that graph
that we saved as g1, give it
a nice title.
So [INAUDIBLE]
publication graph.
Assign a height, a width,
units for that, and then a DPI.
The DPI indicates
the dots per inch,
which basically says a high
quality as that increases.
If you don't do that, it
might be a little bit fuzzy.
As you can see, this
is a little bit fuzzy.
Versus if we look
at the publication
graph here, very nice and sharp
and it's actually very large
and you can zoom in
and it looks good.
I'll leave this part out.
And I think we're good there.
I really quickly want to go
back into our presentation
now that we've covered this.
And we'll walk through
the last few stages
on what to do next now
that you've kind of gotten
a whirlwind walk through
of how to do statistics
and some live coding in
R. So for the next steps,
and the kind of
the follow up items
that might be helpful for you.
I will be sharing the slides
in RStudio Colab Instance,
so you'll have the
availability of all this code
and be able to play around with
this data set in RStudio Cloud
without having to
install anything.
You just do it through
your web browser.
So you'll be able to kind of
walk through exactly what I did
and play around with it.
Additionally, working
inside RStudio Cloud
there's actually training
data sets and examples there.
So if you go to RStudio Cloud
Primers it will actually
show you the basics of
how to get started with R,
how to work with data, do
some visualization, tidying,
iteration, which is more of high
level functional programming,
and then writing
functions themselves
which I covered very quickly.
The good thing here is
that these are interactive,
so you're able to write code
and get feedback immediately.
They're ready to go without
having to install anything
and you can't break anything.
You don't have to worry
about installing something
on a Windows versus a
Mac versus a Linux box,
it's just ready to go
in your web browser.
There is additionally
some great books
if you're trying
to figure out, OK
which statistical
test do I need to use.
Learning Statistics with
R by Danielle Navarro
is a great book that covers the
didactic understanding of why
statistics in which to
use, as well as raw R code
about how to do them.
The R for Data
Science book actually
covers examples of going
through R for data science
as opposed to pure statistics,
so doing more programming,
plotting, exploratory
data analysis.
This is a great textbook by
Hadley Wickham and Garret
Grolemund.
And if you're more
interested just purely
in data visualization,
Social Viz by Kieran Healy
is a great resource for
seeing example R code
to create these beautiful
plots and examples like you
saw today.
The last thing I wanted
to go over as well
was the Tidy Tuesday R4DS
Online Learning Community.
So this is that weekly project
I talked about briefly.
Basically a data set gets
uploaded weekly at GitHub.
So GitHub R4DS Tidy Tuesday.
Every Monday on Twitter
we release the data set
and it looks like this.
So a link to the data, an
article about the data,
and then some example plots.
Basically, you just play
around with the data
and you can share
it or just observe
what other people
are doing on Twitter.
And it's a great
way to learn more
about using R in a Tidyverse
with new data sets each week.
Additionally, there's
RStudio Community
where you can ask questions.
So whether it's
questions about IDE
or if you need help with
actual code you can go in here
and ask questions there.
The R4DS online
learning community
has a slack group where
you can also ask questions
and it's a little bit
more private since it
isn't a public facing group.
Anyone can join, but it isn't--
you have to log in to
slack at the very least,
so it sometimes
feels a little bit
quicker to start as you're able
to do immediate interaction.
And lastly, R is pretty
active on Twitter.
Somebody actually collected all
the tweets using the R Stats
hashtag between 2008 and 2018.
You can see there's
almost 500,000 or about
430,000 tweets.
And there are
additional hashtags
you can follow whether it's
RStats or Tidyverse, ggplot,
epidemiology,
Twitter, R Spatial,
there's a bunch of
different resources there.
R Open Sci has a
lot of packages that
may be more specific to
your type of science.
So I covered one example
for kind of neuroscience.
Maybe you're doing plant science
or marine biology or something,
there could be other
packages through R Open
Sci that are useful.
And that's just ropensci.com.
And lastly, if you're
trying to get involved,
the R Ladies global
community is great.
And basically their mission
is to promote gender diversity
in R community.
So this includes under
representation of any minority
gender.
You're able to join
remotely or at actual
meet ups in your city, and
it's a great initiative
to staying involved and
contributing to this community.
And lastly, I know that
this kind of was very quick
and it can seem intimidating
to get started with R.
And maybe you're like oh,
I'm later in my career
or I'm a little bit older.
Jenny Bryan, who I
have a huge amount
of appreciation and respect for,
talking about this with Sharla
and talking about how everyone
has their own career path.
And it can be a slow career
movement or a fast curve
movement.
That's OK.
So it kind of
reinforcers that you
don't have to get
started super quickly
and you can kind of go
through it at your pace.
And then lastly,
obviously Hadly Wickam
is pretty well known
in the R community
and he's still Googles
stuff and finds it
through the Rstats hashtag.
So again, no matter how
experienced you are,
it's OK to make mistakes,
it's OK to be learning,
and we're all here
to learn with you so.
With that, I'll actually
end a little bit after time
but still have some
time for questions.
I appreciate your
attendance today
and I'll take questions now.
Thanks.
So the key differences between
RStudio Cloud and RStudio
is RStudio Cloud is hosted,
so you connect to it
purely through a web browser.
You don't have to
install anything.
And then the RStudio Desktop
is actually installed
on your computer,
whether it's your laptop
or your desktop computer.
Both will look exactly the
same once you're actually
using them.
OK, some people asked about
the Tidyverse library.
It's basically a [AUDIO OUT]
so packages give you
those functions
that allow you to do
more things in R without
having to write it by hand.
And the Tidyverse
a meta-collection
of other packages that
fall along in that syntax.
You can actually create
websites using RMarkdown.
It produces HTML content.
So you can look at the blogdown
or the distill packages.
Those actually allow you to
create entire websites or blogs
in R. And that's how I
run my personal blog.
There's some great
resources at blogdown.
There's actually
a book about it.
And distill has
its own website--
distill.rstudio.com.
There we go.
So this actually walks
through kind of in long form
exactly what we covered today.
I didn't want to just read
this out in front of you,
but it basically gives a similar
presentation to what I did.
Although I have changed it
up a little bit since then.
But this could be useful if you
maybe don't like videos as much
and you want to read
through something.
You can just search for
the mockup.netlify.com.
It's actually the first
post I have there.
The Tidyverse is
one package but it's
a meta collection of packages.
You can actually--
someone's asking
about how do you
know which functions
are available in each package.
A lot of packages will have
their own website or a CRAN
page.
So if you think of like
the Tidyverse, [INAUDIBLE]
website where you can look
at all the different things.
So it's just tidyverse.org.
You can look at the
different packages
that are here and available.
You can click on the
individual packages
and there's everything from
cheat sheets to example usage,
where it is in the lifecycle,
and then references to all
of the different functions
that are available in it.
You can also do this from
within RStudio Cloud.
So if you-- let's see if
we can get back in there--
I'll log back in real quickly.
So you can actually
just type some code.
It will kind of show you
exactly what that function is.
So if you did like question
dpyr or question mark ggplot2,
that will open up in the Help
pain an example about that.
So it will give you links
to external resources
as well as some information
about the package.
You can also do that
same syntax in terms
of question mark followed
by the package name
and then tell it what are the
functions you're looking at.
So let's do annotate.
So if I did it on
just one function
it will give a description,
the example arguments
that are available, the details
and a quick example of it.
You can label a
factor as anything.
So someone's asking about
labeling a factor as say you
like less than 24 as
opposed to 24 written out
as text, that label could
be used as a character.
So you could actually
just type in less than 24.
So example like factor
x label less than 24.
Something along those lines.
This wouldn't actually
give you the full code,
but just an example of this
is now a character vector
and could be labeled that way.
Any other free R training
programs, courses, MOOCs?
I'm a big fan of
the cloud workspace,
these primers, because
you're able to do them
super quickly and
for free in terms
of go into here to the basics,
click on visualization,
and you're able to get started
with both kind of example
queries, actually
running code, and it
will give you outputs here.
So you can actually practice
inside of a workspace
or just go through
these primers.
I think that's about it.
Yeah.
A lot of similar questions.
I think I covered it.